When I say Labor Day, what do you think about?
Barbecues?
Parades?
The end of summer or the beginning of football season?
Well, we at Adecco think about those things too,...
...but we also think about, well, work.
Hey, we connect more people to more jobs than anyone else in the world,...
...so labor is a big part of what we do.
Well, getting back to Labor Day.
Did you know that Labor Day began in New York City in 1882?
It started with sort of a parade.
Actually, it's more like a rally.
20,000 people marched up Broadway to demand an eight-hour work day.
They carried banners that read "Labor creates all wealth"...
...and "8 hours for work, 8 hours for rest, 8 hours for recreation!"...
...and "Adecco totally rocks!"
Okay, maybe not that last one, but you get the idea.
After the parade, there were picnics all around the city.
Workers and celebrants ate Irish stew, homemade bread and apple pie,...
...and enjoyed fireworks at night.
The day was a big hit.
Two years later, the Central Labor Union...
...designated the first Monday in September as Labor Day.
And on June 28th, 1894, Congress made it a national holiday.
So to all of you who work, either on the job, looking for a job,...
...at home with the kids, or wherever you may be, here's to you.
You're what Labor Day's all about.